today's episode is sponsored by blinka
Stu the app that lets you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blink it's totally
free and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blink ascom slash david pakman
I put the link right below this video
so we have to have a conversation today
that might be difficult for some in our
audience but it must be done because the
stakes are really high at this point
think back to 2016 before the November
of 2016 election you had people on the
Left who were saying things like you
know if it's Trump versus Hillary I'd
rather it be Trump really I'd rather it
be Bernie or Jill Stein or some other
so-called real leftist but if it's Trump
versus Hillary Hillary will just
reinforce the status quo Trump will be
so different
maybe wacky that he will totally shake
up the system and set the stage for a
real progressive in 2020 we have almost
four years now of a trump presidency and
it hasn't happened and it's another data
point that these ideas of acceleration
ISM haven't worked now I know you might
be thinking David you're wrong it's you
know we need eight years of Trump
instead of four for this to work or
David you're wrong
Trump has shaken things up such that we
now will become super progressive or
something the answer to those rebuttals
is no and I'll go through them one by
one in a moment but first we need to
sort of understand what we're talking
about when we talk about acceleration
ISM there's narrow acceleration ISM and
then there's like the broader colloquial
use of the term acceleration ISM so
narrow acceleration ISM if you if you
look at the oranges or origins of these
ideas generally refers to capitalism and
socialism and the idea is in order to
get rid of capitalism you accelerate it
right you go to like uber super ultimate
extreme free-market capitalism that will
more quickly break and then in will come
radical change socialism some of
completely different systems so in other
words feed capitalism so that it
collapses now if we say acceleration ISM
more broadly it's not so much about
capitalism versus socialism necessarily
it's the idea of accelerate the
destruction of the current system by
putting in place crazier and crazier
leaders so that we speed up the system
failing and then being able to replace
it with something better some other
people characterize it as burn it down
to rebuild it properly so when some on
the Left said back in 2016 I'm a bernie
person so I'm like 98% on board with
Bernie's ideas you know maybe I'm 60% on
board with Hillary and I'm 10% on board
with Trump but I still want Trump
because Trump will violate norms and
violate conventions and do things that
will accelerate the total downfall of
the system and then we will usher in a
real era of true progressivism in 2020
so listen we've got four years of Trump
three and a half years so far it has
done very little for the progressive
movement in any real way we got trumped
the most lethally incompetent president
we've had in the modern political era
he's failed on everything right the
bogus tax reform plan the trade war
disaster with China he failed on
coronavirus he's failed on you know of
immigration he tried but failed to get
rid of the affordable care act but
certainly we've not made progress when
it comes to health care
he has failed failed failed while making
the United States a laughingstock and
what it led to is a center-left
Democratic nominee of Joe Biden who may
win or may not win so despite those who
in 2016 said Trump will accelerate you
know some kind of progressive revolution
and it's better that he become president
than Hillary because she will
essentially maintain the status quo it
didn't happen it didn't happen so what
do we have to do to hold those folks
accountable people saying if it can't be
a progressive that meets my standards
then I'd rather it be Trump because his
failures will usher in progressivism
well they haven't they've ushered in
being out of the Paris
in Accords and falling further and
further behind on taking care of the
environment in the planet they've
ushered in a coronavirus response that
has completely failed and led to
unnecessary death
they've ushered in tax cuts that have
completely failed to actually improve
circumstances and now we just find
ourselves with more damage to undo if
Joe Biden does win in November and takes
over in January he simply has more
damage to undo than what we would have
had Donald Trump lost in November of
2016
so let's now deal with some of the
inevitable talking points here's one you
know what David four years of Trump
would have ushered in progressive change
if the DNC hadn't stolen the 2020
Democratic nomination from Bernie and
given it to Joe Biden come on guys come
on guys
Bernie lost by a lot before he dropped
out Bernie was already losing the
Democratic primary by a couple million
votes Bernie lost Super Tuesday and then
he lost Super Tuesday number two and
then he lost Super Tuesday number three
at that point we already were starting
to deal with coronavirus stay at home so
yes centrist candidates like Pete and
Amy got out of Biden's way but this
doesn't change that Bernie never had
more than mid to high 30s support period
no matter how many other candidates
there were the acceleration estar Gyu
man's about that inevitability were
simply wrong and to be perfectly frank
how weak is your argument that if four
years of Trump was going to bring in
progressive change inevitably
it simply failed because Pete and Amy
got out and that's why Bernie lost I
think that it's a very weak argument if
it could so easily be interfered with by
Pete and Amy ending their campaigns to
help Joe Biden now there's going to be
another argument which is Trump's
presidency will be acceleration estate
years of Trump instead of four
right in other words we were right in
2016 that Trump instead of Hillary would
usher in progressive change through a
burn it down and no
to rebuild its sort of perspective but
four years isn't enough we need a full
eight years of Donald Trump it's a full
it's a completely post hoc
rationalization none of these folks were
saying back in 2016
Trump will reinvigorate the progressive
movement but it'll take eight years
instead of four they are having to say
that now because they were just wrong in
2016 so we need another framework
Hillary Clinton was no progressive but
if Hillary Clinton were president our
coronavirus death toll would be lower it
wouldn't be zero but we have studies
from Columbia University and others if
we had a coordinated stay at home one
week earlier we could have avoided
30,000 of the hundred thousand deaths if
it had been two weeks earlier we might
have avoided fifty to sixty five
thousand of the hundred thousand deaths
that would have been different if
Hillary were president Hillary were
president we would still be in the Paris
climate agreement and we would not have
softened fuel emission standards we
would not have a ridiculous trade war
going on with China so let's really
understand that when people say now if
it's not Bernie
I'd rather another four years of Trump
why four years of Trump messed up so
many of our systems but those systems
aren't really any closer to going away
they're just messed up four years of
Trump damaged our planet more than it
had to and we can't get those four years
back four years of Trump didn't get us a
progressive nominee history tells us
that progress comes in modern political
systems like the one we have in the
United States progress comes in steps
now I've given these examples before but
they're important to repeat
you've got the Progressive Era of the
1890s to the 1920s
you've got the New Deal era officially
it's 1933 to 1939 some people consider
it to be a little bit bigger than that
you've got the civil rights era from the
end of the 1950s until you know into the
60s it's easy to look back now and say
wow look at that insane list of
accomplishments now with the benefit of
hindsight we see it but if you were in
the middle of the progressive era of the
late 1890s and it too early 1920s 30
years
long time if you're in the middle of it
it probably doesn't feel like such
significant change but when you look
back and you see wow the community
activism slowly eking out a better
Supreme Court a lot of the Progressive
Era reforms were upheld because we had
the right Supreme Court right because
Supreme Court justice Charles Evans
Hughes justice Oliver Wendell Holmes
Herbert Hoover nominating Charles Evan
Hughes Teddy Roosevelt nominating Oliver
Wendell Holmes
it didn't seem like big progressive
change at the time but some of the
biggest advancements in that way that we
now take for granted during that era
came from exactly this type of
incremental ISM it's boring I know it
but it's what worked when you look at
would trump get to replace Ruth Bader
Ginsburg or would Biden get to replace
Ruth Bader Ginsburg if she retires that
may not seem like that big of a deal to
some people but history tells us that it
is look then at the New Deal era of the
30s under Franklin Delano Roosevelt this
came out of the Great Depression it
included changes that now are considered
to be just fundamental parts of the
fabric of the country but they weren't
burn it down revolution things it was
regulate the banking industry programs
to support farmers the unemployed young
people elderly folks creating social
security which is huge of course you
didn't get that by burning down the
system you didn't get it by saying hey
you know what
instead of FDR because it can't be a
super progressive let's select some
right-wing nut no it didn't happen that
way history tells us
lastly the civil rights era right of the
50s into the 60s filled with protests
and sit-ins and rallies and a ton of the
day to day elements that we often see
today and and say today really would
need to be scaled up but a lot of the
progress was 1954 Brown versus the Board
of Education that was an early movement
an early moment in the civil rights era
and it was a decision made by the
Supreme Court reinforcing the importance
of who gets to pick the justices is it
Trump or is it Biden
1956 and double-a-c-p works
within the judiciary to win
desegregation of the bus system 57
Martin Luther King creates the SCLC to
support local protest movements you've
got the new North Carolina drugstore
sit-in in 1960 which sparks more sit-ins
these were not burn it down acceleration
esthetical that were incremental and
we've wasted four years with donald
trump we've wasted four years where some
progress could have been made and you
now would have to redirect the ship so
to speak less so then it will have to be
redirected when Donald Trump eventually
leaves we have a choice there's no
reason to make the same mistake again in
November people's lives are riding on it
and we need to understand the same
argument that's being made now about
listen if it's buy it and give Trump
another four years people made that
argument in 2015-2016 it failed it
failed look at what happened there is no
empirical case for saying well another
four years will finally fix it it's not
how the system is designed it's not
what's going to happen if you disagree
let me know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
and I welcome your comments also
remember to sign up for the David Pakman
show audio podcasts a lot of you that
watch our clips on YouTube may not know
we've got an audio podcast free every
day get it on iTunes stitcher Google
Play podcasts our website it's
everywhere and it is one of the more
popular ways to consume the show every
day quick break right back after this
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read ten books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka Stan what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blankets to get
a sample first just think how much you
can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire nonfiction book in
just 15 minutes I recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
Stephen Hawking this is a book that I
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
accom slash david pakman I've put the
link right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the show
richard ronke and Ann crear are our
today's new David Pakman show members of
the day I also want to say thanks to
someone who has been with us for almost
five years and is today's longtime
sustaining member that's Anthony Cunha
Anthony thank you for your support
join these great people grab a
membership at join pakman.com if you
want to take advantage of the Memorial
Day special which is now three days in
the rear view mirror the code still
works the code is Memorial 20 all one
word all lowercase Memorial 2-0 big
savings on the membership of your choice
at join pakman.com okay it's Thursday
meaning we have the latest jobs numbers
plus we have updated first quarter GDP
numbers it's all pretty ugly but I will
sort of mention at least a few possibly
less than horrifying components to some
of this data
first of all GDP you might remember that
about a month ago we got the first
quarter GDP estimate which was a decline
of 4.8% it's now been updated often in
the 30 days after the estimate we get an
updated GDP number the first quarter GDP
number has been made worse by being
increased to a five percent shrinking of
gross domestic product during the first
quarter now in a moment
well actually not in a moment right now
the White House is a planning not to
release expectations for the second
quarter and this is a part of the
proactive propaganda attempt to cover up
historically unconscionably bad economic
numbers that we are going to get at the
end of July and into the end of August
during into the end of August about the
second quarter the White House clearly
seeing the writing on the wall and they
are not going to be publicizing these
expectations they will get them from
their economic teams but they will not
be publicizing them and the numbers for
GDP for the first quarter getting worse
from 4.8% down to 5% down a sign of what
is to come now jobs numbers
last week another 2.1 million people
lost their jobs new unemployment claims
last week 2.1 million
new unemployment unemployment claims now
understand that before coronavirus
700,000 job losses in a week was the
record I believe it was sometimes and
sometime in the 80s I don't remember if
it was 82 or 88 I've mentioned it before
but losing 700,000 jobs in a week was
the record for the United States we've
now had about 10 consecutive weeks of
anywhere from 3 to 10 times those
numbers 10 consecutive weeks so we now
have first couple weeks it was about 6
million jobs lost each week than 5
million then around 4 million jobs for a
couple of weeks then we lost 3 million
jobs a week for a couple weeks and in
total 41 million new unemployment claims
have been made during the era of
coronavirus the last 10 weeks remember
that before coronavirus we estimated the
labor force was about a hundred and
fifty-eight million people so that means
that 26 percent of the total workforce
in 10 weeks lost their jobs insane
unimaginable economic destruction now a
few things to bear in mind this doesn't
mean that now 41 million people are
still out of work some of the people who
lost their jobs you know nine weeks ago
ten weeks ago they've gotten new jobs
and in fact if you look at continued
claims ongoing unemployment claims it
actually has come down so two weeks ago
we were at 25 million active unemployed
people that is now down to 21 million so
that's something it means that in the
last week more people got off of
unemployment than the number that got on
the most likely scenario based on these
numbers is that we are going to see very
high unemployment numbers for a very
long time even if every state was able
to reopen today to 75 percent you would
still see very big numbers continuing
certainly into 2021 and there are
questions about could this be you know a
two year recovery could this be a five
year recovery we just don't know but the
point
forget about this being fixed to any
significant degree before the November
election
and this is why yesterday's segment
about garbage math is so important
because there's a good chance that after
disastrous second quarter numbers we
will start to see some improvement from
these absolutely you know bottom bottom
bottom lows in the third quarter and as
we start to see that recovery in the
third quarter hopefully if we just
continue straight on
if wave one and wave to blend together
and things continue to worsen this may
not happen but if you start to see some
improvement in the third quarter
the administration is going to start to
focus on growth rates I already told you
now they're floating air travel
reservations are up a hundred and twenty
percent well yeah but they were down to
just four percent right they were down
96 percent they are now recovering from
being only four percent of what they
were so the base rate matters we've
talked before yesterday about how this
will impact propaganda around GDP
numbers propaganda around jobs and
unemployment numbers so I want things to
improve as rapidly as possible but I
also don't want to get bamboozled into
thinking that things are better than
they actually are nor into being
bamboozled into believing that Donald
Trump fixed something that he actually
had nothing to do with so the numbers
are clearly going to keep getting worse
before they get better including in the
quarter we're currently in the second
quarter we won't know how bad it got
this quarter until around August 1st or
even September first the official dates
for q2 GDP are estimate I believe on
July 30 and update on August 30 so be
prepared be prepared is the point and
don't fall for garbage math as we will
undoubtedly be subjected to by this
administration here's one of those a
broken clock is Right twice a day sort
of moments brazen FoxNews propagandist
Sean Hannity scolded Missouri partiers
for not wearing masks on Memorial Day
and seemed to be defending George Floyd
who was killed tragically by police
recently a
story that has gone viral let's take a
look at a couple of clips here's Sean
Hannity just seeming to make sense on
the topic of partiers massing together
on Memorial Day without wearing masks
take a look Rory
Lake of the Ozarks packed with
partygoers this holiday weekend look I
understand these are young people
experts keep saying over and over
they're at a much lower risk but if they
do get this and again there's no mass
wearing here that I see or not much at
all I see no social distancing but if
they get the virus and then are in
contact with older and more vulnerable
Americans that could be a disaster for
others that's why in the short period of
time it's only temporary
you can't social distance please wear
the masks do it for your mom your dad
your grandma your grandpa my humble
advice you don't have to listen to me
I'm not a doctor now I wish Hannity had
said I'm not a doctor in his segment
about hydroxychloroquine a few weeks ago
talking about a prophylactic regimen of
hydroxychloroquine but he is right this
is temporary we're all in it together if
you're in a large crowd if you're close
to people just wear a mask let's get
through this together help out your
fellow humans part of why it's so
surprising that Hannity is saying this
is that he's been a locust of
misinformation and disinformation
propaganda since the beginning of the
corona virus pandemic it's not just his
hydroxychloroquine cocktail recipes that
he gave out Hannity has been insisting
that Trump had the quickest and best
response to the virus that's a laughable
joke Hannity was arguing for a while
that coronavirus was less of a threat
than the seasonal flu even in mid-march
Hannity was still citing seasonal flu
numbers as this completely meaningless
comparison to a novel coronavirus now at
the same time for a while the same
people who are now saying wear a mask
were saying you don't need to wear a
mask now I have to tell you my position
on this has not changed I'm still
skeptical of the need to wear a mask
outdoors when you're not near people if
you're outdoors right on top of people
if you're bunched together in a line for
a sustained period of time if you were
at an outdoor concert certainly the more
we know about the virus the more we
learn that the spread is not really
opening via surfaces really as much as
at once at one point was feared it's
really a person-to-person the more we
learned that the vast majority is
happening indoors the more we learn
about a certain amount of viral load
needing to be transferred from one
person to another for you to actually
catch the the the disease the virus to
be infected and often that requires 10
or 15 minutes around someone not just
passing them on the bike path but it
doesn't really matter it doesn't really
matter you can look at European
countries just spoke to a Belgian friend
who said people aren't wearing masks
outside in Belgium but still hannity is
talking about people behaving
irresponsibly partying in large groups
together with no masks and the real
point is the disregard for the lives of
others and so listen the hypocrisy of
hannity does not go ignored the utility
of masks in reality has not actually
changed but if sean hannity is going to
say this and it might reach people in
his audience it's a good thing one other
hannity example here is hannity
yesterday actually going after the
police in the george floyd killing
saying listen we're not doing you know a
trial by videotape but i don't
understand what cops did here it doesn't
make sense based on the video i've seen
and any opportunity for sean hannity to
brag about his martial arts practice he
always takes advantage of take a look
and again this is not trial by videotape
here that has nothing to do with it
this guy's not resisting on any video we
see you hear him clear clearly saying i
can't breathe isn't I have to imagine
and I talked to my martial arts sensei
trains police officers for free he says
it is scary to him how for most officers
a lot of officers their only option is
what's on their their side arm that's it
or a stun gun did not trained in the use
of martial arts but even if a
rudimentary trainee would say would you
would know how sensitive this is to
one's neck so very interesting sort of
moments of clarity on Sean Hannity
show now there's one other angle it's a
very cynical angle which is that foxnews
is increasingly afraid of getting sued
and though and so they are starting to
be a little more cautious about what
they say regarding masks and social
distancing and the like okay I don't get
the sense that that's what's affecting
Sean Hannity's day-to-day coverage and
lastly remember just because they say
one or two things that make sense these
are not our allies these are people who
profit from spreading lethal
disinformation for political gain align
themselves with the president and
carrying water for Donald Trump their
priorities are access to access access
rather said to elites and politicians
and profit those are their priorities
and you know when they say the right
thing we'll take it it might save a life
it might change the perspective of a Fox
News viewer hey you know what maybe the
police weren't justified in killing
sorta clip killing George Floyd so we
will take it but a future of critical
thinking and empiricism is not going to
be catalyzed by Sean Hannity even if he
says wear a mask for Grandma but to the
extent that he can challenge the
echo-chamber of anybody in the Fox News
audience I'll take it and gladly so make
sure you're following the David Pakman
show on instagram at david pakman show
we've got polls we've got behind the
scenes pictures we have all sorts of
stuff and on my Instagram at David
Pakman people going crazy for my
quarantine before and after picture I
did a split on my Instagram what I
looked like two and a half months ago
before the start of quarantine and what
I look like now it's been a slow change
I barely recognize my own pre quarantine
self check it out on instagram at david
hackman we will take a quick break we've
got some very exciting stuff coming up
later today on the program
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show it is great to
welcome back to the program
congressman ro Khanna who represents
California's 17th district located in
the heart of Silicon Valley great to
have you back congressman appreciate it
David I appreciate your show I
appreciated your show during the Bernie
campaign and look forward to coming on
yes well we will talk about the Bernie
campaign but in terms of where we are
now it were it looks like Joe Biden will
he said he will announce his VP pick
around August 1st is the latest that
I've seen you like Elizabeth Warren as
Joe Biden's possible VP why I do I mean
I obviously I thought Bernie Sanders
would have been the ideal person to lead
us at this time it was a co-chair of his
campaign and the reason is that Bernie
Sanders understood the importance of
movement politics he understood that you
don't achieve anything just having smart
people in Washington and good policy you
need to have a mobilized base and I saw
the passion that he inspired
particularly among young people that
said he's not going to be the nominee
and obviously he's not going to be in
consideration for Vice President is Joe
Biden this and he wants to have a woman
on the ticket and in that circumstance
it's obvious to me that the most
progressive a possibility is Elizabeth
Warren
she's also exceedingly competent I mean
when I have worked with her she really
understands federal agencies she really
understands how the Senate works how the
house works and in fact I had
recommended when it looked like Bernie
Sanders was going to be possibly the
nominee that he picked Elizabeth Warren
but given her expertise and
knowledge of the federal government and
her commitment to progressive ideals so
I think for the same reason she would be
very good for Vice President Biden and
in more urgent given we need a true
progressive in there there's often these
conventional wisdoms which very often or
not are not really that wise about you
know you need to think about what part
of the country you're VP is from in
terms of appealing maybe to southerners
or Midwesterners or you know having a
strategy that appeals more broadly than
a northeastern Democrat however the
latest polling I've seen suggests that
Elizabeth Warren may actually be the
option that gives Joe Biden the largest
polling boost is this something unique
about Warren in your mind or is the the
dynamic this time around just so
different that those conventional
wisdoms maybe don't apply yes I've never
been a big fan of that conventional
wisdom thinking and it's convenient now
it doesn't apply when you have a Bill
Clinton in Al Gore when you have sort of
moderate tickets it seems oh okay let's
double down my view is that the vice
presidential pick should be someone who
people will see as a governing partner
even though I totally disagreed with
them I thought Bush's pick of Dick
Cheney was very strategically smart at
the time people were questioning his
competence to lead on foreign policy and
he was sort of reassuring people saying
look I've got this person Cheney and so
in this case I think people are gonna
ask the question who is going to be able
to help rebuild the economy who is going
to really understand competence in
government and under those metrics I
think Elizabeth Warren really stands out
and I think that's one of the reasons
you're seeing the polling the second
reason you're seeing the polling is a
lot of younger voters and voters of
color actually support her policies
therefore a green new deal there for
Medicare for all their for free public
college they're most affected by student
loans so you're seeing that she has a
lot of support and across the board with
Democrats but also young voters and
finally and this is no detraction from
other candidates the fact is that she
has a tight trusted brand
so I mean if you were to poll Elizabeth
worth it more than me you know even
though I have all the policies a little
more and would be overwhelmingly liked
because people trust her they know her
and I think at a time of crisis that
matters and so just the fact of a
familiarity while I may not be an
advantage in a different election year I
think in this election you're really a
place to her benefit
there is a contingent of those who
supported Bernie Sanders I don't know
what the size of it is I know if you
spend a lot of time online it feels
bigger if you spend more time you know
in Ohio you're knocking it probably
feels smaller of people that supported
Bernie that are not looking like they
are interested in voting for Joe Biden
and I've addressed this before I'm not
planning to shame anybody for their vote
if someone genuinely feels that they'd
rather four more years of Trump than
Biden by all means they should act in
accordance with that but for those who
are looking to either punish the DNC or
send a message or any of these other
things do you have a message to that
contingent of those who were with you
during the primary with Bernie sure I'd
say do it in other ways I mean if you
want to run progressive challengers to
people in the house of the Senate even
if I can't support it I appreciate that
and understand that if you want to have
a challenge to the DNC I appreciate that
and support that if you want to make
sure that in in 2024 we have a
progressive nominee even if you know
it's getting behind whoever even if it's
not the vice president fine I support
that but don't sabotage the progressive
movement by having four more years of
Trump in and that's the reason that's a
sabotage is mostly partly because of the
courts I mean let's assume Bernie
Sanders who knows a few runs again let's
say he became president in 2024 hey you
know I'm gonna in four years older early
eighties and we had eight years of Trump
I mean what could Bernie Sanders do in a
Supreme Court
that was seven to two against us in
agencies that have been totally done it
he would basically basically be a bridge
president then trying to fix the Supreme
Court and trying to undo the damage and
it would take another ten years before
the we had progressive policy on the
other hand let's say we had Joe bagging
and then in twenty four we had Bernie
Sanders or a progressive you know that
then you're at least having more former
progress so I'm pragmatic about it but I
agree altum Utley I think the vote is
sacred and we have to earn people's vote
not to sort of badger them into
supporting the the ticket and so you it
sounds like you don't subscribe to the
more accelaration estai diaz of
sometimes you've got to burn it down to
build it back up or Trump being who
Trump is will accelerate some much more
progressive leftward swing I mean I
guess it didn't seem to happen over the
last four years in the sense that Joe
Biden and ended up the nominee
ultimately but that doesn't sound like a
philosophy you subscribe to I guess I
guess it's a philosophy of a bit of
privilege right I mean even if it were
true and who knows if it were if it were
true that there's gonna be some opposite
reaction are we willing to sacrifice the
the kids in cages in the meantime are we
willing to sacrifice the the Muslim
American Muslims who are not allowed
into this country are we willing to
sacrifice the environmental damage
that's happening every day are we
willing to sacrifice the courts so it
seems to me not consistent with
progressive ideals
every life matters and that the ends
don't justify the means I also don't
think it's necessarily true I mean I
think that Trump will do so much damage
in stoking racial division and stoking
xenophobia
that if he has eight years of it the
next president is probably going to have
to do a lot of cleanup and is it going
to be in a position as easily of pushing
bold progressive ideas whereas if you
have Biden the next president after him
could do that we essentially agree so
let's let's move
to to another topic that I want to talk
about which is the the sort of next six
to 12 months related to coronavirus I
think one of the worst things that could
happen would be sort of overlapping
openings and closures meant to try to
try to play whack-a-mole while we still
have no effective treatment and we still
wait for a vaccine
what are you sort of thinking is the
most likely trajectory over the next six
months given what we're seeing at the
state level right now and federal
leadership on the virus well appreciate
your saying that I mean first we have to
look at what could have been done and
you look at countries like South Korea
now South Korea did things about
compromising people's privacy which we
would never do here but they get some
very simple things they told everyone to
wear masks right in the beginning our
CDC was going back and forth on that
they had us testing out there and they
worked even with private sector testing
companies our government was arrogant to
reject not only W World Health
Organization's tests but also to reject
the private sectors help in testing so
and we should have had a lockdown much
earlier I called for a national lockdown
in March and if we had done that for a
couple of weeks we would have avoided
some of the the the debts even New York
and I I don't want to cast blame on any
particular leaders but if if they had
locked down when Santa Clara County did
the former CDC heads estimates that you
know almost 80% of deaths could have
been avoided all this is to say that
these should be lessons going forward
and my view going forward is we ought to
have clear national guidelines on where
we need for masks where we need for
social distancing where we need policies
in terms of non gathered not gathering
in in large areas
I understand locally people can then
determine whether rather to start some
business or not but I think there has to
be some national guidelines as
well and then we need a greater focus on
on testing and a greater focus on the
adoption you know Google and Apple and
it's in my district they've come up with
this app it would be voluntary in terms
of people display and disclosing their
information and the information would be
private but I think we need to try to
get them more adopted to that I think
that could help I want to talk about
testing in a moment but let's talk about
the earlier lockdown briefly what was
the date that Santa Clara locked down do
you remember offhand mark mark 16:16
okay so that's a little I've said that
somewhere between March 5th and 15th we
had nearly a hundred cases in China
Italy already was around four to six
thousand and we had a several hundred
cases that to me seems like it would
have been enough information for Donald
Trump to say this is going to be tough
but I need all 50 governors with me we
need 30 days of stay at home it probably
would have had to be extended another 30
it would have ended on May 5th like that
60-day period could have been over by
May 5th or May 10th or May 15 and when I
mentioned this to Joe Rogan last week he
said there was no app you wouldn't have
gotten anybody to do it on March fifth
or tenth or 15th because there was no
appetite for it doesn't that miss that
40% of the country will essentially
agree with whatever Donald Trump
proposes and maybe it actually could
have been done at that earlier stage
Cody did this and on March 30th when she
had the benefit of being married to an
epidemiologist at Stanford who told her
that every single day that you wait
you're actually creating exponential
risk and that's why she convinced the
six bay area counties to shelter in
place in Santa Clara County which was
one of the earliest hit has only had a
been 120 debts as a result of her
decision so and and they complied very
strongly people in my district have
complied
I believe if Trump had done that people
would have complied I have no doubt
about it
and my guess is he probably would have
made that decision in retrospect because
it would have put him in a better
position for re-election if he could
have done that in March and come April
mid April or May we had avoided the
worst of it and the
he was reopening I think he
underestimated how severe this was going
to be how long it was going to last and
you know it's a little bit of Monday
morning quarterbacking but I think what
it really shows is the need not just for
us to listen to science that's everyone
says that and that's the easy part but
how do you create a culture where we
communicate science in a way that speaks
to people's lived experience and isn't
projected and what is that dialogue and
communication and how do we facilitate
that and I think we have large questions
in our democracy that to understand that
because climate change so many of these
issues are going to raise similar
questions where your intuition is
contradicting scientific information and
how do we act and then in those cases
this is one of the things I talked about
earlier this week that's scary which is
that what is really a medical situation
has become a proxy culture war where
it's about tyranny and liberty it's
about the mask as a political signal and
it's completely divorced from from the
scientific realities and I understand
like tomorrow on the show I'm going to
do a hypothetical what would be a good
reason for a left-wing skepticism of a
total lockdown and it's going to be a
sort of very careful examination of
different elements of this but the way
in which this has become a culture war
that is divorced from science it seems
acutely disturbing I think we on the
Left have to be careful too because I
think when we start the conversation
with people on the right don't believe
in science I think it puts people in a
defensive posture right and I think that
there's probably here's what I think is
actually going on I mean this is just a
big speculation but my sense is that
people just have different probabilities
of risk and different tolerance for
death and different tolerance for
economic decline and what you're really
seeing is a conflict of those values so
I don't think people on on the right are
out there saying well we don't believe
maybe there's a small minority but the
vast majority are not saying we don't
believe covet exists or is being
transmitted or than masks help but
they're saying you know the probability
is so small
all and get on with it and we're rugged
and toss them this is what we're going
to do the question as a democracy is how
do we have the conversation to be more
about the clash of values which is
really where it is and a give-and-take
rather than the politicization of
science and I think what you're seeing
is the politicization of science is
really about a clash of values so people
are trying to politicize science to have
their value that the economics matter
more than saving a certain lives last
thing I want to touch on in terms of
testing what is the number of daily
tests that you believe is where we
should be it what from what I'm seeing
if we don't get to 500,000 a day there's
not really even very much to talk about
but that right it's got to be somewhere
between one and a half and five million
tests a day where do you have a sense
from the CDC that you know if ideally it
would be a million tests a day but short
of that around four to five million a
week I think that would be important but
it's not just the test it's then what do
you do with the testing what are you
doing in terms of contact tracing what
are you doing in terms of isolating
these individuals what are you doing in
terms of testing the right people that
they're testing folks who are in pact
circumstances or essential workers so
yes we need more capacity for testing
but when you look at a country like
South Korea and they didn't do
everything right they had violations of
civil liberties but because of their
SARS experience they had a lot of
cultural norms about what they will do
with the testing and who to test and how
to contact trace and hopefully our
country will develop some of that having
gone through this experience yeah
certainly it's not just the testing but
the testing is uh it's it's necessary
but not sufficient I guess is the point
that your that your we've been speaking
with congressman ro Khanna who
represents California 17th district
congressman always great having you on
appreciate it thanks for having me the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
so I'm getting more and more calls from
viewers and listeners horrified that
Donald Trump is going to cheat his way
to re-election later this year and your
fears are real and that Donald Trump
will try to cheat the question is
whether he will succeed and what we mean
by cheating and Heather Digby Parton has
a really great article in salon about
this and I'll mention a few of her
points in a few of mine she points out
that as real as Joe Biden's leads in the
polls right now may well be Donald Trump
will try to cheat and it was going to
take everything we have to keep him from
re-election now what do I mean by
cheating and I want to be really careful
here by cheating I mean that failures
and vulnerabilities in the system will
lead to Donald Trump maybe being
reelected even when a Biden win would be
the will of the people so I'll give you
an example of what I mean by that
Trump's opposition to vote-by-mail this
has been a big thing over the last three
or four weeks whether we call it literal
cheating legal cheating or simply
suppressing the will of the people
Trump trying to win by making it so
fewer people vote is cheating in the
sense that it cheats democracy it's
circumvent the will of the people
yesterday I told you about you know all
the garbage math that we're going to be
hit by in the coming months where people
who don't even understand growth rates
and percentages are going to quickly be
told that we're seeing the fastest
growing economy in history in the
upcoming third quarter when what we're
seeing is the start of a recovery from
the largest declines of the last hundred
years so that's not literally cheating
but it is bamboozling vulnerable people
with mathematical lies another example
Trump has an Attorney General in place
William bar William bar has made it
clear that he has absolutely no moral
and ethical scruples whatsoever he will
stop at nothing to help Donald Trump now
you might think well hold on a second
David William bar did recently say he's
not going to prosecute Obama in the fake
Obama gate scandal he must realize that
that's not okay he's doing the ethical
thing no
all that means is that William bar
recognizes that in the large scheme of
things a good prosecuting Barack Obama
for the bogus Obama gate Fiasco first of
all there's no crime Obama committed so
what could you really prosecute him for
he recognizes that it's not the right
tool to use to try to propel Donald
Trump to re-election Election Day is
going to be absolute mayhem in red
states you're gonna see people show up
to vote and told that they're not
registered due to voter purges you're
going to see the polling places that are
open we don't know how many it's going
to be it'll depend on the virus you're
going to see some polling places
completely overloaded in key swing
states like Wisconsin and Pennsylvania
and Florida you're going to see some
so-called Patriots showing up to do
security at polling places which of
course will be hugely intimidating to
certain voters you're going to see even
in states that go for vote by mail a
concerted effort to disqualify ballots
for bogus reasons you're going to see
coronavirus probably keep more democrats
at home than republicans because
democrats are more likely to understand
and accept the medical science of
coronavirus when republicans are more
likely to ignore it so understand that
we have an election coming up and it's
not unique in this sense but it's
exacerbated acutely in this particular
election we have an election coming up
where one candidate wants to reduce the
number of people that vote and the other
candidate wants as many people as
possible to vote lastly understand that
this is only partially because of
coronavirus even before the corona virus
pandemic in 2017 there was a poll done
asking if Trump suggested postponing the
election would you support it more than
half of Republicans said they would more
than half of Republicans before the
virus said we would support postponing
the election just on Trump say so it's
not going to happen this year remember
that it's up to the states there's not a
federal election in November what we
have is an election of a federal
government position
President of the United States done by
50 individual state elections each state
election is administered independently
but the anti-democratic tendencies of
the Republican Party have been clear for
a long time it's scaled up because
Donald Trump knows it's not thinks he
knows and he's right that if he can keep
disproportionately Democrats from voting
including by blocking vote-by-mail he is
in a much better position to potentially
defeat Joe Biden in November so what do
we have to do well number one we've got
to completely overwhelm the voting
booths in November and I hate that it's
the only surefire method but if we
completely overwhelm the voting booths
and vote-by-mail absentee ballots
everything that ensures that we win
Trump can only cheat so much and if we
don't allow him to prevent people from
voting one way or another that is very
very important now secondly we've got to
keep pushing on vote-by-mail
particularly in certain states and I'm
going to address that a little bit more
in the next segment but understand if we
overwhelm the voting booths he can't win
we just need to do it so let's continue
our discussion of ways in which Donald
Trump may try to subvert or challenge
the will of the people in November of
2020 to get himself reelected let's talk
about Michigan Michigan has been a big
target of Donald Trump's ire Michigan
has been looking at vote-by-mail they
decided they are going to be sending
absentee ballot applications to every
voter now I want to remember let's not
forget that Michigan is not sending an
absentee ballot to everyone
Michigan is sending an application for
an absentee ballot to anybody who wants
one Trump tried to argue on Twitter last
week that by sending a ballot to
everybody Michigan is doing something
wrong remember that Michigan is sending
an application to everybody and in
Michigan the lieutenant governor garland
Gilchrist the second set to MSNBC that
he believes Trump realizes he's likely
to lose Michigan in November and so he
is
kind of stirring up all of this
controversy over vote-by-mail in order
to create a pretext to challenge the
results in michigan the lieutenant
governor recently said in an interview
with MSNBC quote I think that the
president wants to set us up so that
there can be a conversation about the
legitimacy of an election that he is
looking to lose that is a really
unfortunate thing that's not how we do
democracy here in the United States and
we need to be ready to respond to that
forcefully so you don't need to think
too hard to realize there's a very good
chance Trump is going to call election
results into question in 2020 in in the
November 20 2011 Trump won in 2016 and
he still says it was rigged so
understand for three years Donald Trump
has been attacking the trustworthiness
of an election that he won so of course
he's going to challenge the results if
he loses in November
now whether he'll get away with it we'll
discuss in a moment in terms of Michigan
Trump won Michigan it was really close
Trump won Michigan by about eleven
thousand votes over Hillary Clinton that
was 0.3 percent in terms of a margin of
victory right now Trump is losing to
Biden in Michigan in the last four polls
Trump is down by three four seven and
eight
okay the way to prevent Trump from
credibly arguing that the Michigan
results are bogus is to defeat him in a
landslide to defeat Trump so
overwhelmingly in Michigan that there is
no credible way for him to say it was
rigged and 10,000 votes 15,000 votes
were the difference maker
they are going to bring out every trick
they can and Michigan is very likely to
be a primary target which is why Donald
Trump keeps talking about Michigan all
the time now it's also always personal
for Donald Trump part of Donald Trump's
focus on Michigan is that he's been
feuding with Gretchen Whitmer who's been
the Democratic Michigan Governor
overseeing the coronavirus response and
the
is a surefire way for Donald Trump to
attack you she has been standing her
ground against Donald Trump when it
comes to coronavirus and policy her
polling is much better than Trump's in
terms of coronavirus handling so that
makes Trump absolutely furious now let's
talk about whether this will work I've
said before if Trump loses he will
likely claim it was rigged but he will
leave it's not likely to be what we
would call a peaceful transition of
power so when you look back at the bush
handoff to Barack Obama when you look at
the Obama handoff to Donald Trump we had
what we would call a peaceful transition
of power the outgoing president inviting
the incoming president to a White House
visit even though these were hard-fought
political battles we we checked every
single box for what we call a respectful
proper peaceful transition of power I
would expect Trump to continue being the
petulant child that he's proven himself
to be refusing to welcome Joe Biden to
the White House refusing to do these
perfunctory things that outgoing
presidents do and quite frankly I don't
care
I don't want to get ahead of myself if
Biden wins if Biden wins the only thing
that will matter is that Joe Biden won
Trump can do whatever he wants as long
as he leaves and we can get back to
something more normal now let me throw
out one other thing I've been thinking
about if Donald Trump loses and claims
that it was rigged and still ends up
leaving it could be a good thing for the
country and what I mean by that is
Donald Trump has successfully ignored
loud 'add not flaunted floated checks
and balances ignored separations of
power emoluments attacking the media
accusing TV hosts of murder Justice
Department deciding hey we're not going
to prosecute someone Michael Flynn who's
already pleaded guilty it might actually
be reassuring for the United States to
see Trump argue I really want I really
want I really won and still be forced
out because it would reassure us that at
least some of our institutions are still
working
seeing that an institution still works
seeing that a check-and-balance still
functions seeing Trump
to say it was rigged but still having to
leave could be exactly the reassurance
we need that we will start to get back
to something approximating a more normal
government it's a thought and in the end
all that matters is that he does leave
that's all that really matters in the
end we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p
here's a funny kind of interesting but
also a prescient voicemail this is from
a foreigner who just doesn't understand
how trump is able to get away with lies
all the time take a listen hey David
this is Andre calling from beautiful
Germany yes I've got a question could
you please explain to me why the media
is Barack Obama Joe Biden and the rest
of the Democratic Party do not rip Trump
apart for the PS and the lies he keeps
telling on a daily basis I mean any of
these lies and false allegations which
Trump has been spreading over the last
couple of weeks would have been
political suicide in Germany yes I mean
to me the media and the Democrats they
seem like victims that are too afraid to
stand up against their bully what do you
think about that yeah so listen I
understand the total bewilderment around
the world at what is going on from
bizzle laughingstock and yet he doesn't
seem to sort of suffer the consequences
this is only partially because of
Democrats and it's only partially
because of the media I've talked before
about how when Trump lies at a press
briefing and he gets called out on the
lie he will tell three more lies and
then move on to the next reporter and
it's very hard to control that or he
will simply end the press briefing early
and these things in the United States
are not proving to be political suicide
why because you have such a partisan
environment that half the country
doesn't care or half the country sees
Trump leaving early from a press
briefing as a sign of power or they
simply believe everything he says we
have such a broken critical critical
thinking has broken in the United States
and so I get it people you know my
family from Argentina my family that
lives in France my family that lives in
Israel
they see what's going on in this what
how are people not just calling Trump
out and how is it not hurting him
politically you have to understand the
degree of ignorance and partisanship
that exists in the United States to
really understand the answer to that and
it is very very ugly on the bonus show
today we will talk about George Floyd we
will talk about Kelly Lafleur we will
talk about Ron de santis and much much
more get instant access to the bonus
show at join pakman.com very much look
forward to speaking to you that
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blink Asst the app
that lets you read or listen to an
entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinka store free
and save 25% off of a subscription when
you go to blink is comm slash david
pakman i've also included the link right
underneath this video